6 25 on your Finally Friday what's cool
at school oh this is really cool one
local elementary school made the most of
the annual week of respect last month
students at the Clarence Piggott Academy
took part in several activities put
together by councilor Wade Rogers
including sending fun friendly postcards
to someone they don't know fifth grader
Sophia talked about the elementary
school version of see something say
something I haven't seen anybody get
bullied but I have seen people get
teased and I either tell the teacher or
tell them to stop third grader Mateo has
learned about an unchecked cycle of bad
behavior
being bullied and they get mad they
might do it to another person and they
might go to another person and then goes
on and on and on and counselor Roger
says kindness is contagious and they can
be kind to one another and it does kind
of rubs off to everybody else everybody
will help somebody or say some nice
things even Smiles just simple little
things that just make somebody else's
day a little brighter you how about that
speaking of kindness our thanks to
Mauricio Marin from the school
district's Communications office for
sharing the news about the week of
respect we always want to know what's
cool at school you got something let us
know cool is cool under the Community
tab of our website or you can just email
cool at school at 8newsnow.com